this is Startalk the level of hype that
goes out with press releases when you
publish some paper it's completely out
of proportion to the result you'd see
the reproducibility crisis and sorry
about the reproducibility crisis alright
so in in and up by the way now your talk
about a problem in the scientific
community inside won't let the public
alone for the moment right now let's
just mind our own house okay go so Amgen
some years ago did a study so the
pharmaceutical fired by a bio bio
chemical company right and they took 53
studies that we're not just published in
peer-reviewed journals it was on cancer
for cancer looking for cancer drugs okay
53 studies not just published but
highlighted in the editorials of the
issue of the journal they were in as
potential major breakthroughs and they
put a whole bunch of people on it put a
whole bunch of money in it tried to
reproduce them 89% of those studies were
irreproducible Wow bad that's bad I'm
going to say I'm not a good number
so just to be clear for people know what
how when a scientist use of the word
irreproducible that doesn't mean they
couldn't figure out the experiment it
means they did the experiment I think
did not get the same results samer so
that's what it reproducible beans and so
if you don't get the same result then
one is wrong the others right the other
is wrong that is right or they're both
wrong right they both can't be right
that's right and so this is a problem
this is a problem just recently very
energetic psychologists rounded up a
couple hundred of his colleagues and
tried to reproduce a hundred and
some-odd afree at how many of there were
experiments they've been published in
behavioral psychology okay of order half
of them could not be reproduced after
them couldn't be reproduced so so what
is this attributable to I mean it's is
it
is it a matter why wait just to be clear
I have to be clear and they would round
this out but that's going to be clear
there is no requirement cosmic
requirement that your research will
ultimately be shown to be correct
okay most research is shown to be either
unimportant or an interesting or
sometimes wrong right there's no wrong
do
there but when you want to assert a new
emergent scientific truth you cannot
link it to a single research result
that's it because we recognize as a
community that we can have bias we're
human like anybody else and I can advise
I didn't know about so now I get I do an
experiment David comes in it so you know
I love you Neil but let me just double
check you and he gets a different result
finds that I made an error or maybe we
both made errors and you need a third
person to come in and show that that
happens too so you don't give your
thesis that will not be broached in this
garbage if you like this please remember
everything that we do can be found
commercial-free plus exclusive original
content all on Startalk all-access calm